Musik
Mein Name ist Stefan Michael Tietze und zusammen mit Florentin Will moderiere ich das Podcast-Ufo. Das ist lustig. Zusammen erzählen wir Gags aus unserem Leben, Dinge, die wir uns ausgedacht haben oder erfinden uns immer wieder neue spannende Improvisationsstücken. Also sozusagen ist es eine multimediale Comedy-Show. Zusammen haben wir Spaß und reden mit euch über die Dinge, die uns beschäftigen. Viel Spaß! Die erste Folge im Liegen. Ne, das stimmt nicht. Wir haben schon die eine oder andere horizontale Folge aufgenommen. Ich erinnere an Hamburg. Von der Qualität her meinst du? Ja, genau. Achso, richtig. Eher qualitativ. In der Spannungskurve haben wir sehr oft horizontale Folgen aufgenommen, aber in Hamburg zum Beispiel, in Hamburg zum Beispiel habe ich auch im Ligen moderiert, habe mir auch ein bisschen gehört, dann ist die Stimme immer so ein bisschen eingequetscht. Deswegen können Leute, die im Ligen auch nicht gut singen, zum Beispiel. Keiner Funfact. Wie zum Beispiel Kurt Cobain, der liegt ja im Grab. Und, hat er seitdem eine gute Platte rausgebracht? Nein. So. Wollen wir? Leg mal los. Wollen wir mal mit so einem ganz authentischen Gespräch irgendwie rein starten? Ja, lass uns mal mit einem ganz authentischen Gespräch in den Podcast starten, einmal zumindest. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe dann Johanna angerufen und habe sie, warte, ich fange nochmal an. Authentisches Gespräch, Take zwei. Und bitte. Auf jeden Fall habe ich Johanna dann gesagt, die ist schon klar, es gibt da so eine ganz tolle Erfindung, die nennt sich Kalender. Die kannst du dir vielleicht auch mal anschaffen und dann habe ich einfach aufgelegt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Nachricht angekommen ist, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die richtige Person angerufen habe.
Oh, das Podcast-UFO kommt durch die Tür.
Oh mein Gott, jetzt sind wir drauf.
Jetzt sind wir schon drauf.
Sorry, Leute, wir waren gerade so tief in unserem Gespräch.
Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Herzlich willkommen zum Das-Podcast-UFO-Podcast.
Für euch haben wir ja noch gar nicht gerechnet.
Oh mein Gott. Natürlich, hi,
wie immer mit
Steffen Tilti heute mal wieder bei uns. herzlich willkommen, und Florian Wollny ist damit auch am Start, natürlich, herzlich willkommen. Dankeschön, ihr hört das Podcast UFO, der erfolgreichste Star Wars Podcast südlich von Dagobah, geschnitten wegen Authentizität. Wir sind ja heute nicht zum Spaß hier, wir wollen ja heute ein bisschen über ein intimeres Thema reden, das sich auch schon länger beschäftigt, und du hast mich gebeten, normalerweise, Aids, richtig. Normalerweise überlegen wir das Thema immer gemeinsam, aber heute Morgen bist du auf mich zugekommen und hast gesagt, hey Flontien, das ist vielleicht ein Thema, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen krasser, das ist ein bisschen persönlicher, das ist ein bisschen intimer für mich, das liegt mir irgendwie, ich beschäftige mich damit innerlich schon seit Tagen und ich möchte es einfach ansprechen und du bist ja heute hier, um dein Buch vorzustellen, das jetzt tatsächlich endlich auf den Markt gekommen ist.
Erklär doch mal, also wie war das für dich, wie war die Reise, wie war der Schaffensprozess, wie fühlst du dich jetzt, wo das Buch endlich zu kaufen ist, wie geht es dir? Ja, erstmal danke, dass du das aufgreifst, so. Ich habe es noch einmal gesagt und es war nicht selbstverständlich, dass wir jetzt nochmal hier nochmal so ein Ernstsystem anschneiden. Aber ich habe in der Tat jetzt ein Buch endlich mal fertiggestellt, was mich seit
lange thematisch beschäftigt.
Es geht um Schockdiagnose Harnröhrenkrebs. Ja, wie kam es dazu? Ich meine, das ist ja ein Roman. Es ist ja ein Science-Fiction-Roman. Wie kam es zu dem Titel? Es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie autobiografisch oder so. Obwohl dein Bild ja ganz gross vorne auf dem Cover ist, ne? Also das ist ja ... Ja, das habe ich mit Photoshop. Ist ja deine Harnröhren tatsächlich, muss man ja sagen. Ja, genau, das habe ich mit Photoshop ein bisschen zurecht, damit es passt. So ein kleines Schnurrbart drauf, ne, ist ja auch ein bisschen lustig, ist ja auch für die, ist ja ein Kinderbuch tatsächlich geworden. Es ist ein Kinderbuch mit vielen Bildern, auch es ist immer illustriert gerade auch. Man muss aber auch ganz ehrlich sagen, es ist nicht etwas, was mich persönlich beschäftigt, aber was viele, was meine, zum Beispiel viele Haustiere, die ich hatte, beschäftigt hat. Ein Thema, was sicherlich auch an Kinder herangetragen werden sollte. Da gibt es eigentlich nur Fachliteratur, diese grossen Wälze, man kennt das und Kinder werden darauf gar nicht vorbereitet. Ich mag es auch nicht, wenn ein Buch so lang ist, dann denke ich mir oft so, hey, komm zum Punkt, wo ist die Essenz? Ich habe schon in der Schule immer, wenn es irgendwie dann geredet wurde, erster Weltkrieg, zweiter Weltkrieg, gesagt, jetzt Leute, komm doch mal zum Punkt. Was ist es, ich habe immer direkt, weißt du, den Mittelfinger zum Lehrer gesagt, bin rausgegangen, habe gesagt, das Hakenkreuz an die Tafel gemalt. Ich habe gesagt, das Leben findet da draußen statt, nicht hier im Klassenzimmer. Was ihr mir hier erzählt aus schaubigen Geschichtsbüchern, das hat damit da draußen überhaupt nichts zu tun. Da bin ich rausgelaufen, habe aufgelegt, habe die Tür zugemacht.
So, deswegen fand ich es so erfrischend, dass du ja auch mit dem Maskottchen Horni da irgendwie auf diesem sensiblen Thema... Horni der Hahnröhre, genau. Das ist so ein bisschen erfrischend, soll das sein. Das Horni begleitet halt die kleinen Kinder. Und ich finde, was auch immer so wichtig ist, diese Kinderbücher, die irgendwie dann auch Rassismus darlegen sollen, die Quadrate, die den Kreisen verfeindet gegenüberstehen, diese Rassismusmetaphern, das verstehen die doch gar nicht. Die Erwachsenen verstehen das, aber die Kinder verstehen das nicht. Deswegen wird bei mir klar gesagt, es gibt keine Schönreden mit Blumen oder so, nein, Horny hat Harnröhrenkrebs. Das ist doch der erste Satz, ne? Also da machst du keinen grossen Hehl drumrum. Doch, das geht sehr lange. Der erste Satz ist sehr lang. Die Folter bildet sich erstmal, damit der Punkt krass ist, damit das Kind geschockt wird. Es muss erst eine Beziehung zu Horny aufbauen, damit dann ab Seite 30 der krasse Punkt kommt. Schockdiagnose, Harnröhrenkrebs, Horny stirbt. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, also ich will da ganz ehrlich sein, weil als ich das Buch als erstes mal in der Hand hatte, dachte ich mir, nicht schon wieder Harnröhrenkrebs. Ich meine, wir hatten 2007 irgendwie, ich gucke in die Röhre, ja, also diese Bücher, diese ganzen, ich bin dann mal kurz weg. Auch die Fortsetzung von der ist kurz weg, er ist wieder da, wo man dachte, man hat ihn übersprungen, besiegt den Krebs, er ist wieder da. Für mich der Cliffhanger des Jahrhunderts. Ja, gut, danke schön, danke schön. Ich dachte mir, wo ist er denn jetzt? Ja, das fre mich, dass es dir gefallen hat. Aber ich finde, das Thema Harnrönenkrebs ist ja für dich wie so ein Prisma, bei dem sowohl alle Themen, ist ein roter Faden, ein roter Pfad. Kann man sagen. Wo alle Themen, die dich beschäftigen, irgendwo zusammenkommen. Und durch dieses Prisma betrachtest du auch ganz viele Facetten des Lebens und der Existenz des Menschen an sich.
Richtig.
Und das hat für mich überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Ach so, das ist so ein Thema, mit dem ich so ein bisschen kaleidoskopartig auf die Welt schaue.
Und ich sag mal, Harnröhrenkrebs ist so vielschichtig.
Das hat mich ganz oft interessiert, aus wie vielen Aspekten es eigentlich besteht genau.
Und dann habe ich mich jetzt in diesem Buch besonders auf die Kinder gestürzt, mit diesen Aspekten, dieses Schockmomentes. Was heißt Schock für dich? Schock ist für mich, wenn die Welt von jetzt heute auf morgen schlagartig eine Wende erfährt. Zu einer Zeitumstellung? Zum Beispiel. Wie hast du die Zeitumstellung wahrgenommen? Hat mich sehr schockiert. Waren Treffer direkt ins... Ich war in der Tat auf einer Party länger, also ich sag immer so ab zwei Uhr aus Versehen. Moment, wir haben jetzt zwei Punkte in dem Satz. Ich war auf einer Party, erst mal schon mal der erste Augenbrauenhochzieher bei Stefan Teitel. Ich bin jetzt auf Promotournee mit meinem Harnröhrenkrebs Buchhorny. Und da hat man ja auch viel mit Partys zu tun, also man ist ja viel unterwegs. Ja, ich denke, wo fängt Haarenrührkrebs an? In der Küche. In der Küche, ja. Und deswegen war ich dann auf einer Party und dann ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass Zeitumstellung war und ich dachte mir, ab zwei Uhr ist es so gesellschaftlich akzeptiert zu gehen, aber es war ja eigentlich schon drei Uhr. Da hat mich die Zeitumstellung ganz schön genutzt, vor allem bei dem Handy, also wir haben ja iPhones, kann man mal sagen, weil wir reich sind, kann man auch sagen.
Im Vergleich zu Menschen, viele Menschen können sich keine iPhones leisten.
Im Vergleich zu afrikanischen Kindern sind wir sogar unverschämt reich.
Ja, also das iPhone, auf das ich absolut verzichten könnte, ich könnte sehr gut ohne iPhone leben, damit könnte man ein bestimmtes gesamtes afrikanisches Dorf sowohl ernähren als auch eine Bildung ermöglichen, die es ihnen ermöglicht, langfristig wirklich gutes Leben. So ein bisschen bleachen. Ein bisschen Farbe ins Gesicht zumindest. Ja, so ein bisschen wenigstens. Das kann sich ja niemand angucken. Ja, und da hat mich dann, weil das iPhone sich das normal umstellt, dann die Zeit von sich aus, automatisch, ungefragt, einfach so, hat es mich genatzt, kann man so sagen.
Ich war dann plötzlich bis drei Uhr ja eigentlich da.
Das sind auch so What-Momente, so What-Was ist jetzt gerade los, Moment, hallo.
Erst mal Stopp gerade.
Erst mal ganz kurz Stopp, kann niemand die Zeit anhalten, die rast gerade.
Ist ja eine Art Zeitreise auch irgendwo, ne? Geschnitten wegen schlechten Witzen.
Das war das literarische Duo mit Florentin und Stefan. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da dingle dingle ding. Hier hätten wir exakt einen Bruch jetzt anstellen können, um ein normales Gespräch weiterzuführen. Hast du verpasst diese Chance? Ich bin gespannt, wie wir aus diesem Loch jetzt wieder rauskommen. Ich glaube, wir sind sehr gut darin, aus Löchern wieder rauszukommen. Wenn wir eines bis jetzt geschafft haben... Nice what she said! Komm, gebe ich dir. Denn man muss ja sagen, wir sitzen heute mal wieder uns leibhaftig gegenüber. Hallo Stefan, erstmal hallo. Hallo Florian. Man kann ja erstmal auch eine ganz normale Begrüßung, auch ein bisschen Smalltalk, warum nicht im Smalltalk mal ein bisschen. Wie geht's dir, was treibt dich gerade so? Du meinst ja, du hättest ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen, also was ist da los? In der Tat, ich war wirklich beim Wrestling und habe seitdem Rückenschmerzen, aber ich habe zugeguckt, ich habe beim Wrestling zugeguckt. Passiv Wrestling sozusagen, ist ja oft viel gefährlicher als Aktiv Wrestling. Also einer aus unserer Firma wrestelt wirklich so als Hobby, die machen das einmal im Jahr, machen die so eine Veranstaltung, wo sie dann wrestlen und dem geht's super. Und dir geht's sehr schlecht. Und dem geht's super, der hat wirklich harte Kämpfe geforcht, irgendwie vier Kämpfe oder so, ah 20 Minuten und ich stand im Publikum die ganze Zeit und ich habe Rückenschmerzen davon getragen. Wir haben ja schon entabliert, dass du wahnsinnig empathisch bist, nur du fühlst ja immer sehr mit und das hat auch keine Grenzen. Also wirklich, du bist ja dann, du hast ja dann auch wirklich echte Schmerzen und echte Probleme. Und eines Tages wirst du vielleicht sterben, wenn du irgendwie siehst, wie eine Familie Enten oder Autobahn überfahren wirst, dann fällst du einfach um, To. Wie geht es dir denn? Wir haben auch schon darüber gesprochen, wir machen gar keinen Sport. Eigentlich so richtig machen wir keinen Sport. Ist das so ein bisschen die Frage, angenommen wir ziehen im nächsten Jahr zusammen. Ja. So sind jetzt fest zusammen, kann man mal sagen, wir ziehen im nächsten Jahr vielleicht zusammen auch. Wir wollen den nächsten Schritt gehen tatsächlich. Wir wollen den nächsten Schritt wagen. Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, ich glaube, es ist das Beste, wir sind bereit, diesen nächsten Schritt zu gehen. Ähm, nee. Sorry, das mit dem Smartock funktioniert einfach nicht. Es klappt nicht. Ich bin einfach nicht cool im Smartock. Es macht mich echt nervös. Ich kann mit dir über alles reden und habe mit dir schon 42 Stunden lang geredet, aber bei Smalltalk werde ich einfach nervös. Es ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was man machen kann.
Tränen, wenn dieses Wasser in die Augen steigt und so viele Gag-Dokumente durchblättert werden, komme ich schnell wieder raus. Ich brauche irgendwas, irgendein Gag. Geschnitten wegen depressiver Selbstanalyse. Wir haben letzte Woche so ein bisschen über Sprichwörter gesprochen, als ich auf diesen Text gekommen bin. Ewige Thema Sprichwörter, ich finde es so gut, dass wir uns thematisch... Du kannst nicht, wenn ich irgendwas anfange, direkt deinen Augenmove machen, Und ins Augenmove, wie er sich in seine Augen fasst und dann aufstöhnen. Weil es ein Kommentator geschrieben hat, muss ich nochmal an unsere Anfänge zurückdenken. Und zwar waren wir am Anfang ja noch eine ganz andere Sendung. Wir haben ja auch so Prank-Calls gemacht. Wir haben ja einmal zum Spaß bei so einem Massagesesselhersteller angerufen.
Dinge, die man sich heutzutage überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen könnte von dem seriösen, mittlerweile Erwachsenen gewordenen Top-Moderatoren Stefan und Florian. Das macht man heute nicht mehr. Wir haben uns ja ganz stark verändert und darum soll es halt auch ein bisschen... Lass uns doch mal anrufen. Jetzt. Einfach sagen, wie hat sich das Leben verändert seitdem? Wie ist es Ihnen ergangen? Erinnern Sie sich noch? Wir waren die, die damals einen Sessel kaufen wollten. Wie geht es Ihnen eigentlich noch? Sollen wir das wirklich machen? Nee, auf keinen Fall. Aber es war ungefähr die gleiche Zeit, glaube ich. Ja, ich glaube, uns gibt es langsam ein Jahr. Geschnitten wegen belangloser Nostalgie. It's a hard knock life for us. it's a hard, it's an Auftakt. Okay, drei, vier. It's a heart. Nein, warte. Wie zählt man das ein? It's a heart not life for us. It's a heart not life for us. Will we win it, make a drink, and you have to kiss the next day. It's a heart not life. Hallo meine Damen und Herren. Jetzt kommt das authentische Vorgespräch. Ach ja, so und dann war die Claudia da plötzlich. Die Claudia, ne? Und dann habe ich da ganz, ich habe da ein bisschen auf den Hintern geklopft und habe ihr gesagt, hör mal, das Gerät, was du hinter dir ziehst, das ist wirklich, das ist ganz schön, wow. Ja und ihr, aber sie hat ja direkt die Abmahnung. Direkt direkt. Hä, aber sie hat ja doch eine Hose an, oder? Also du hast ja nicht wirklich auf den Arsch gehauen, sondern auf die Hose. Nein, einfach nur so ein Klaps. Man kann doch die Hose einer Frau berühren. Sie war gerade am Kopierer, bin ich in die Lage gegangen, hab kurz ihr Zopf an dem Zopf-Sieg gezogen, und hat kurz einen Klaps auf die auf die Bäckchen gegeben, und dann bin ich fast er war so typisch Claudia wieder, ne? Oh, scheiss, direkt beschweren, direkt zum Chef und dieses Vollarsch von Dings hat dann direkt die Abmahnung rausgehauen. Oh, warte mal, ich glaube, wir ... Scheiße, oh, Entschuldigung, Leute, jetzt haben wir es gar nicht gemerkt. Wir wussten gar nicht, dass es schon läuft. Herzlich willkommen zum Das Podcast UFO Podcast. So heißt es. Fantastisch. Du bist echt so weird. Unglaublich, ja, wir sind wieder gut drauf, wir sind wieder in einem Raum, wir geben Gas. Und Loflundin liegt los mit deiner ersten Anekdote. Wie kommt der erste Anekdote? Wir schnitten wegen schlechter erster Anekdote. Stefan, deine Prognose für den neuen Harry Potter Film. Wie geht's weiter? Das nächste Buch wurde angekündigt, es soll ein neues Buch geben, es soll ein neues Film. Nee, der nächste Harry Potter Film ist ja, wie wir nicht wissen, ein langes Musikvideo. Und J.K. Rowling, die jetzt auch ihre Musikkarriere beginnt. Ja genau, mit Fantastic Beats. Ja. Ja, Alter, weißt du, man kann aber jetzt irgendwie Harry Potter Musik, Musikwortwitze mit Harry Potter und Musik. Harry Potter und der Feuer...
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Und die Kammer des
Beckens, ja,
der Gefangene von
Bassdrum.
Der Gefangene in der Bassdrum.
Der Orden des
Drum and Bass,
ja, passt,
Teil 5, ich weiss gar nicht, was Teil 5 ist, und der Stein der DJ Bass-Notenschlüssel, passt auch. Oh, die Heiligstimme des Tones, die Heiligstimme des Tones.
Die Heiligstimme des Tones 2.
Die Freundin von Harry, Harmonie Granger.
Ja, geht doch, es geht doch, man muss es mal machen.
Du musst deine Scheißrubrik einfach nur anfangen, dann passiert schon was. Keyboard.
Ja, ähm, Bellatrix, The, La Grunge, The, The Cure, äh, der, hier, Albus Dumble, Bongo, Dumble, Four on the Floor, Der dicke Wildhüter, Bongo, alle da. Hier diese Klingeldinger, wie heißen sie? Rassel, Rassel meinst du? Rassel, der Orden des Phonetik, alles da, gut. Vielen Dank, wir verdienen hiermit unser Geld. Vielen Dank, das war schon. Flättert fleissig, spendet uns Geld. Das ist aber die richtige Reaktion, eine Frechheit-Folge raushauen. Einfach nur, wenn man uns unterstellen kann, dass es eine grosse Frechheit ist. Das war, Leute, ich mag euren Podcast ansonsten sehr gerne. Und ihr habt mir auch schon bei vielen Hausarbeiten und Busfahrten geholfen, aber die Folge war mir zu frech. Das war zu spitz, zu viel Pfiff, zu viel Peck, zu töricht, möchte ich mal aussagen. Die war wirklich ein bisschen zu töricht. Ach, meine Lieben, Leute. Naja, naja. Aber was glaubst du, tatsächlich passiert? Der neue Harry Potter Film, die Leute erwarten ihn heiß begehrt. Was könnte passieren? Ich glaube, dass Harry Potter zu dem Bösen wird, weil man hat Harry Potter ja noch nicht auf dem Poster gesehen, man hat ihn noch nicht im Trailer gesehen. Er wurde aber auch auf dem Set gesehen, ziemlich viel. Oft Harry Potter? Ja, war tatsächlich oft dabei. Deswegen kann er sein, dass er böse wird. Oder einfach so ein Crossover zwischen Family Guy und Harry Potter. Das würde ich machen, wenn ich eine ganze Filmreihe, wenn ich Multimillionärin wäre, wie J.K. Abrams, würde ich einfach sagen, fuck it, für den nächsten Film. J.K. Abrams, finde ich sehr lustig. Danke, wir machen einfach einen Crossover mit Futurama oder mit irgendwas ganz Absurd. Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Oder was sich einfach mal wieder ein bisschen Realismus in die Harry Potter Welt zu bringen.
Warum ist im neuen Teil Voldemars Tod, der neue Bösewicht ist einfach ein Typ mit einer AK-47,
der durch Hogwarts rennt und einfach die Schüler nie der mehr.
Oder der neue Bösewicht ist einfach Putin oder so.
Einfach so was ganz komisches.
Ein iranischer Diktator.
So ein Iran, genau.
Der die Atombombe baut.
Der aber auch keine Chance hat, weil es alle Zauberer sind.
Zumal die Probleme der Muggelwelt in Harry Potter ja überhaupt keine Rolle spielen.
Muggel?
Muggel, ja. Dass sie nicht einfach mal sagen, ey Leute, wir können zaubern, wir bringen einfach mal eure Wirtschaft in Ordnung. Oder einfach mal irgendwie... Das ist mir nicht schlecht. Die gehören sich da einen Scheiss drum, ne? Die könnten einfach alles... Aber wie viele Flüchtlinge könnten in Hogwarts leben, mit diesen grossen Teilen? Ja, oder allein in diesem einen Zelt, das ja innen riesig ist und außen gross. Ja, genau. Aber die sagen, was, die verhungern da gerade, ist mir scheissgeall. Lass uns doch ein bisschen Quidditch spielen! Wuuuuhuuhuup! Alle passen in meinen Zink und außen groß. Aber die sagen, was die verhungern da gerade, ist mir scheissgeil, lass uns noch ein bisschen Quidditch spielen, wuhu, alle passen in meinen Zink und hat mir das Zelt. Haha, scheiss drauf, Hogwarts ist nur einmal im Jahr, finde ich großartig, finde ich sehr lustig, sollten wir mal machen, genau wie, es gibt immer diese lustigen Sketche, dass man schimpft auf den Erbauer des Todessterns, weil der ist so einfach zu konstruieren. Ja, der hat so eine offensichtliche Schwachstelle. Und der hat diese offensichtliche Schwachstelle zweimal gebaut. Und dann gibt es das ein lustige Video, wo der Architekt zum Wort kommt und eine Pressekonferenz abhält und dann sagt, ja Leute, das ist nicht grösser als eine Wumpratte, dieser scheiss Schacht da. Ganz kurz, ich konnte nicht wissen, dass die Universums Space-Zauer vorbeikommen, die mit ihren Space-Zauberkräften plötzlich genau in diesen Schacht schiessen können. Das ist so unwahrscheinlich. Ich habe eine Riesenstation erbaut, die unfassbar gross ist, wie ein Stern gross ist, und es kommt einer mit einem Zauberer, kommt vorbei und schiesst da rein. Wäre du, worauf soll man noch alles achten? Ich meine, uns wurde eine Woche davor die Pläne gestohlen, in denen genau diese Schwachstelle beschrieben ist, man hätte da irgendwie ein bisschen Knete reinstecken können in dieses Loch, hätte man machen können, sorry, mehr Kulpa, aber mein Gott, ich kann ja auch nicht um alles kümmern, Leute. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut, weil eigentlich sind Jedi ja Zauberer. Ja. Deswegen finde ich Harry Potter und Star Wars als Crossover, Crossover, auch gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich. Wahrscheinlich sind aus den Jedis einfach Zauberer geworden, weil Star Wars spielte ja in der Vergangenheit, haben wir schon etabliert, long time ago. Das heißt, aus den Medichlorianern ist vielleicht Harry Potter geworden. Wahrscheinlich sind sowieso alle Universen alles nur noch eins. Wie viele Medichlorianer glaubst du hast du? Ich glaube so eineinhalb. Und sind Medichlorianer krebserregend? Ich glaube, ich habe einen Medichlorianer und so einen behinderten Bruder, so Benichlorianer. Den er eigentlich mitschleppen muss. Der mitschleppen muss, genau, der immer so, ja sorry, mein Bruder muss auch mitkommen, es ist okay, wenn ich trotzdem zur Party komme. Aber tatsächlich, wenn ich so eine Reihe wie Harry Potter geschrieben hätte, ich fände es immer so saulustig, wenn du so eine Bücherreihe hast, jedes Buch hat 500 Seiten, sieben Bücher, ein enormes Schriftwerk, wenn da so ein Satz drin wäre, der einfach random ist, irgendwie zum Beispiel, wenn J.K. Rowling, zum Beispiel, Albus Sammeldeutsch, Schwul, genau, sowas zum Beispiel, oder J.K. Rowling erwähnt in einem Nebensatz, dass Voldemort Italiener ist, so, das wird nie wieder aufgegriffen, oder irgendwie erwähnt, nur so, oh mein Gott, das ist Voldemort, der übrigens in Palermo geboren wurde, also wir müssen ihn besiegen und du und du, ihr müsst den Zauber lernen, alle so, bitte, was?
Der übrigens Vegetarier ist, ich bin das nicht recht, deswegen glaube ich, können wir auch nie ein Buch schreiben, weil ich hatte viel zu viele Gedanken und dann musste ich da noch irgendwo, würde ich diese Gedanken unterbringen, würde es aber vergessen und nie wieder aufgreifen, deswegen werden ganz oft zu Sätze wie, ja Harry Potter hat schon mal ein Schmetterling getötet, brutal, als er noch klein war, und es wird nie wieder aufgegriffen werden, nie wieder aufgreifen. Deswegen werden ganz oft zu Sätze wie, Harry Potter hat schon mal einen Schmetterling getötet, brutal, als er noch klein war. Und nie wieder aufgegriffen wäre, nie wieder eine Rolle spielt. Oder einen Schmetterling als Geisel genommen, um irgendwie länger aufbleiben zu können, als Kind, um ihn so ein bisschen zu etablieren, figürlich tatsächlich. Aber falls ihr euch fragt, wie denn Stefan tatsächlich als Autor sich schlagen könnte, haben wir ein kleines Gustestücker für euch vorbereitet, denn Stefan hat ein bisschen in seinen alten Kindertruhen, hat er nochmal so den Bären mit dem Loch im Schritt gefunden, wo man sagt so, ach ja, das war ja auch meine Jugend, das würde ich eher gerne vergessen, aber er hat Dinge gefunden, die es nicht zu vergessen gilt, er hat, sag es. Inspiriert von so ein bisschen dieser Fallen-Rubrik, wo Kinder, Kid Theater heißt es, wo Kinder Theaterstücke schreiben über den Titel, Die kriegen nur den Titel von einem berühmten Film, der gerade in die Kinos kommt, und müssen daraufhin dann ein Screenplay schreiben, was Jimmy Fallon dann mit einem berühmten Schauspieler, wenn er mitspielt, dann quasi vorspricht in so einem Table Reading. Kinder haben eine unglaubliche Fantasie. Genau, und daraufhin habe ich mal im Schrank gesucht, was ich noch so für lustige Geschichten habe, die ich mir als Kind geschrieben habe.
Und ich bin in der Tat auf ein Schulheft gestossen, wo ich damals Aufsätze geschrieben habe über Dinge, die einfach Aufgabe waren.
Wo man hier zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt aus der dritten Klasse.
Das heisst, du warst wie alt?
Das war in der dritten Klasse, neun, zehn. warst wie alt? In der dritten Klasse.
Neun, zehn. Zehn sowas, ne?
So, die Aufgabe war folgendes.
Ich möchte euch ein bisschen entführen jetzt mal. In eine andere Zeit,
als es noch keine Sorgen gab
und die
und die Phantasie des Kindes
unbegrenzte Weiten
einnimmt.
Aufgabe. Schon sehr interessant. Erfinde eine Phantasie des Kindes unbegrenzte Weiten einnimmt. Aufgabe, schon sehr interessant, erfinde eine Phantasiegeschichte. Stell dir vor, ein Wesen von einem anderen Stern landet auf der Erde, was kann geschehen? Berücksichtige die besprochenen Schreibhinweise. Erstens, Überschrift, zweitens, Einleitung, drittens, erzähle Einzelheiten ausführlich, viertens, beschreibe das fremdede Wesen genau, fünftens erzähle Gedanken und Gefühle des fremden Wesens und sechstens verwende die wörtliche Rede, siebtens finde einen passenden Schluss.
Wie gut ist das denn?
Autor Stefan Tietzel.
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn. Guido macht Mist. Weit, weit von hier im Universum war ein kleiner Planet namens Dofodoria. Entschuldigung, Dofoderia. Dort lebten Wesen, die die Erde erkunden wollten. Eines Tages flog Guido der Alien los. Er war dick, gross, niedlich und grün. Er flog weit, weit in unser Sonnensystem bis zu unserer Erde. Er landete auf einem Hubschrauberlandeplatz. Unwichtige Teilen. Guido wunderte sich, warum hier überall so grosse Häuser standen. Er wusste es nicht, aber er war in New York. Okay, okay. Er antwortete in Dofoderisch ,,Ni l'r'allai din' aham werlahera derla in velen'". Er hätte doch einfach Guido sagen können. Der Junge namens Tim sagte, ,,Ich glaube, du musst erst mal unsere Sprache lernen". Sie ginge nach Hause. Dort angekommen fragte Tim Guido, ,,Sprich mir nach, Tim". Guido antwortete ,,ete, Time. Nein, korrigierte Tim, es heisst Tim. Guido sagte jetzt, Timme. Tim meinte, so lasse ich es gelten. Jetzt gehen wir aber erst mal ins Kino. Jetzt wo du ein Wort kennst, können wir ins Kino gehen?
Dort angelangt hatte Guido vor der Popcorn-Maschine Angst, weil er dachte, sie könnte explodieren.
Auf den Plätzen sassen allerdings nur Tim und Guido, die anderen waren alle vor dem Alien geflüchtet, da sie Angst bekam. Was eine geile Wendung, ein geiles Sinn.
Du musst mir Notizen machen.
Als der Film endlich losging und er an die Leinwand projiziert wurde, war Guido höchst beeindruckt.
Der Alien, der eben zur Erde geflogen ist.
Bewegende Bilder!
Als im Film dann eine Frau bedroht wurde, zerriss Guido die Leinwand. Daraufhin rannte er weg. Tim rannte ihm nach und fand ihn auf einer Bank, allerdings nicht im Sitzen, sondern stehend. Tim sagte zu ihm, ich glaube, es ist besser, wenn du wieder nach Dofoderia gehst. Guido antwortete, Nila, Denla, Nuosbent, Hara, Freund Tim. Tim setzte hinzu, Kara, Freund Guido. Dann, einige Minuten später, konnte man das kleine Raumschiff am Horizont verschwinden sehen.
Ende. Das ist die Geschichte, die ich je gehört habe. Das ist so gut. Ach, warte mal, die Note gibt's auch noch. Er war auf einer Bank, aber nicht sitzend. Es gab übrigens nur ein Gut. Es gab kein sehr Gut, es gab nur ein Gut, weil bei Du hast das fremde Wesen genau beschrieben, nur gelungen stand und nicht gut gelungen, weil ihr habt nur gesagt, er war dick, gross, niedlich und grün. Das hat ja offensichtlich nicht gereicht. Offensichtlich hat es nicht gereicht. Ich fand es echt gut, die Twists waren nicht schlecht, es hat lustige Gags drin, die einfach, und das meine ich, das sind diese Dinge, die ich eben auch gesagt habe, es würden so Dinge einfallen, die einfach nirgendwo wieder aufgegriffen werden. Alle R rennen weg, das ganze Kino ist leer. Plötzlich er hatte vor der Popcornmaschine Angst, weil er dachte, sie könnte explodieren. Ja, vor allem, es ist ja so lustig, weil man nicht nur die Gedanken eines Kindes verfolgt, sondern auch die Gedanken eines Schülers. Der sich überlegt vor allem so, wie bringe ich diese Story zu Ende? Er kann ja nicht auf dem Planeten leben, weil da müsste ich irgendwie erklären, wie das alles funktioniert und wie sie in Freundschaften leben. Er muss schon weg, aber dass einfach Tim nach dem Verbrüderungsversuch mit dem Kino direkt sagt, du solltest wieder zurückfliegen. Sie sich dann die Freundschaft erklären und dann fliegt er weg. Du solltest wieder zurück. Ist schon nicht schlecht. Ich meine, wahrscheinlich kam in dem Jahr E.T. raus. So ein bisschen eins zu eins Dialog. Kurz danach, wo ich mir dachte, what, Steven Spielberg, was ist los eigentlich gerade? Sorry. Das ist so geil, dass Alien flieht und er findet ihn auf einer Bank, aber nicht im Sitzen. Ja, ach gut, ah, nicht im Sitzen. Das ist so gut, aber auch so ein schönes Thema, er kann ja auch sagen, er steht auf der Bank, aber er sagt, er fand ihn auf der Bank, Achtung, aber nicht sitzen, war ja schon geil, aber auch die, die Erzählreihenfolge ist schön, sie gehen ins Kino und sie waren ganz alleine im Kino, denn alle anderen waren geflüchtet,, und das erzählst du so im Nebensatz,
nebenbei so. Die grosse Action-Sequenz, wo die Polizei gerufen wird, im Film wäre das eine fünfminütige essentielle Sequenz so, sie waren alleine, denn alle anderen sind panisch. Weil's ein Alien ist, weil's ein fucking Aliens ist, Leute. Weißt du nicht. So nebenbei so, ach stimmt, das muss ich auch noch erklären, ne, ah ja, bringe ich irgendwo dem Nebensatz unter. Herrlich, sehr, sehr gut. Guido, er landete auf einem Hubschrauberlandeplatz. Er wunderte sich, warum die Häuser so gross sind. Aber er war in New York. Er war in New York. Sehr gut. Tim, der einzige Deutsche in New York hat ihn auch aufgegriffen. Sehr gut.
Sehr schön.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie viele wir machen, aber ich hab...
Oh, ist das herrlich. Komm, gib mir noch einen,
auf jeden Fall. Also natürlich
auch jeder Aufruf an euch, ich will
die, ihr könnt ja irgendwie mit
eurer Schultheatergruppe diese
Geschichte aufführen und filmen,
das wäre nicht so grossartig.
Verfilmt sie, schreibt irgendwie Fanfiction,
was passiert mit Guido, wie geht's weiter, malt ein
Bild wie Stefan Schabes
Vielen Dank. Geschichten aufführen und filmen, das wäre nicht so grossartig. Verfilmt sie, schreibt irgendwie Fanfiction, was passiert mit Guido, wie geht's weiter, malt ein Bild, wie Stefan Schamesröter diesen Aufsatz abgibt. Herrlich. Okay, hier stehen sogar die Reizwörter noch drüber. Es ist ja immer Reizwörter, die man unterbringen muss. Ah, geil. Reizwörter, Dunkelheit, Schatz und Überfall. Okay, welche Geschichte würdest du heute drüber schreiben? Dunkelheit, Schatz und Überfall. Okay, welche Geschichte würdest du heute darüber schreiben? Dunkelheit, Schatz und Überfall. Ich glaube, ich würde über die innere Zerrissenheit, die man hat, wenn man gerade jemanden überfallen hat, um einen Schatz zu bekommen. Also die innere Dunkelheit. Die innere Dunkelheit, genau, die innere Dunkelheit, die man hat, wenn man gerade den Schatz, irgendwas Wichtiges, eben einem geklaut hat, also Überfall quasi, verhandelt geklaut hat, was man dann fühlt. Darüber würde ich die Geschichte schreiben, wie man sich in innerlichen Konflikten austrägt. Ich würde wahrscheinlich die Geschichte darüber schreiben, wie ein Ninja namens Dunkelheit einen Drachen namens Schatz tötet, um ihm das grosse Schwert namens Überfall abzunehmen. Easy, Reizwortgeschichten sind so leicht. Bin ja gut, man versucht das in zwei Wörter zu übersetzen. Er ging über Fallschirme, so, dass man versucht, wenn man Wörter nacheinander setzt, einfach einen Überfall zu bekommen. Er ging über Fallschirme, weil man gar nicht mehr weiß, wie man diese Klinche in die Richtung lenkt. Man möchte extra clever sein. Okay, go! Gerade wacht ein zehn Jahre alter Junge namens Max in einem kleinen Haus im Dangerwick 13 auf.
Er hört Lärm, er läuft zum Fenster, er glaubt nicht, was er sieht, zwei dunkle Gestalten huschen durch die Dunkelheit, sie scheinen etwas Wertvolles zu haben, denn es glänzt was in ihren Armen. Denn es glänzt was in ihren Armen. Jetzt erkennt Max, was es ist.
Es ist der grösste, schönste und wertvollste Schatz, den das Museum in der Stadt zu bieten
hat, eine goldene Statue, die den heiligen Paulus darstellt. Max sagt sich, ich weiß, dass die Statue nicht Ihnen gehört, ich kenne den Museumsdirektor, der würde die Statue niemals um Mitternacht verschicken lassen, sehr komisch. Er ruft seine Freunde Lukas, Jens und Olli an, dass sie so schnell wie möglich zu ihm kommen sollen. Ein paar Minuten später stehen sie alle vor Max Tür. Sie rennen so schnell wie möglich hinter den Gestalten her. Nach wenigen Minuten sagt Max, Olli, rennt durch die Telefonzelle und ruft die Polizei an. Alles klar, ruft Olli. Max, Lukas und Jens holen die drei Gestalten ein und umzingeln sie. Kurz darauf kommt die Polizei mit Olli. Die Polizei nimmt die Diebe fest und sie kommen mit aufs Revier. Die vier Freunde bekommen einen grossen Lob vom Wachmeister. Danke, ihr hat uns wirklich sehr geholfen, die Diebe werden nämlich in acht verschiedenen Ländern gesucht.
Und nun werden die vier auch Detek4 genannt.
Ende.
Eine Geschichte nur für ein Wortspiel.
Das ist eine sehr lange Feedline.
Ich habe die L-Formel noch nicht...
Das war gar kein Reizwort, D-D-Vier. Die D-D-Vier. Oh Mann. War das der erste Gang, den ich geschrieben habe? Ich weiß es nicht. Das kann gut sein, das finde ich schon ganz gut. Aber auch sehr gut. Einfach komplett am Realismus vorbei. Er wartet erst mal zwei Minuten auf seine Freunde und rennt dann den Gestalten hinterher. Klar, die warten einfach natürlich. Ja, das habe ich glaube ich auch gemerkt beim Schreiben. Aber das ist einfach super. Die gehen sehr langsam. Man merkt ja den zeitlichen Unterschied. Renn du zur Telefonzelle und ruf die Polizei an. Damals gab es noch keine Smartphones, Kinder. Und das klingelt bei dem Smartphone gerade dein Handy, oder was? Ist das dein Ernst? Das glaubt uns keine Achtklasselehrerin ab, dass solche Zufälle passieren. Die würde dir den Aufsatz dem Podcast hier um die Ohren werfen. Zurecht. Was hast du zu mir gegeben? Äh, vier Minus. Es gab keine Noten, okay. Ja, ich auch. Also man muss aber sagen, ich finde, der Zähltempo am Anfang, diese Spannung machen, ist glaube ich schon nicht so schlecht gelungen. Dieses, dass die Dunkelheit nachts ihr Unwesen treibt, gut hat man auch nicht zum ersten Mal gehört. Der Satz ergibt leider keinen Sinn, aber es ist ... Sagt das beim zehnjährigen Jungen ins Gesicht vielleicht einfach. Ja, aber es ist halt so toll, weil man eigentlich den Schritt, den Geschichten erzählen ausmacht, überspringt. Man sagt einfach, es ist gefährlich, anstatt zu sagen, warum ist es denn gefährlich? Man sagt einfach, die Nacht war gefährlich. Okay, gut, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Aber ja, immerhin. Ich habe noch eine kleine Kurzgeschichte. Ach, im Gegensatz zu den Romanen, die wir gerade gesehen haben. Genau, eine kurze Geschichte, knackig. Autor Stefan Thiese. Der sprechende Tannenbaum. Es war einmal ein kleines Dorf namens Wichtling. Die Einwohner wollten immer den allerschönsten Tannenbaum. Familie Dorsten hatte schon einen. Eines Tages passierte es. Familie Dorsten hörte auf einmal einen Quieken. Man konnte deutlich hören, dass es aus dem Tannenbaum kam. Am nächsten Tag stand es auch schon in der Zeitung. Dorstens neuer Baum spricht.
Aber zum Glück stellte sich heraus, dass das Quicken nur ein Eichhörnchen war, das noch im Baum war.
Ende.
Das kam plötzlich.
Oh nein!
Dawstens neuer Baum spricht. Vorzeige Journalismus. Dawstens Neuerbaum spricht. Ja, ich finde es auch so gut, dass die Geschichte alle Erwartungen, die man hat, vollends enttäuscht, weil sie, ja was so ein Tannenbaum? Okay, spannende Abenteuer und dann, nee, das kann er gar nicht sprechen. In den Sals aber so, dass er dochstens neuer Tannenbaum spricht. Und was steht in dem Artikel drin? Mehr Informationen haben sie ja nicht. Das ist nur eine Meldung. Oh Gott, es klingt sehr lust ist nicht sehr lustig. Das Quieken ist nicht eigentlich. Das ist so ein grosser Arsch, wenn man das selber entdeckt und man denkt, man sucht die ganze Zeit das Prositchen wieder drin, weil man denkt, du bist doch keine Vollidon gewesen sein als Zehnjähriger. Doch, aber es kommt immer raus, doch auch du warst als Zehnjähriger. Aber hast du diese Geschichten wirklich mit Leidenschaft geschrieben oder warst du Scheiß, Hausaufgabe, ich schreibe irgendwas hin? Ne, ich bin eigentlich schon immer jemand gewesen, der das sehr gerne gemacht hat. Ich habe gerne Geschichten geschrieben einfach. Wegen das zu anderen Hausaufgaben habe ich das eigentlich relativ gerne gemacht. Ich weiß auch nicht, was man da drin zu sehen vermag. Meinst du, du kannst da drin sehen, dass ich keinen Spaß daran hatte? Nee, aber ich überlege mir einfach nur so, ob das so Faulheit ist, dass man dann so Geschichten auch so schnell wie es geht beendet immer. Das finde ich so gut, einfach so beendet, zack, die Polizei kam, nimmt sie sofort fest, so, Leute, hier ist das Finale, hier ist der Höhepunkt, ihr kannst so alles machen. Ich kann nicht mehr, ich muss echt zum Ende kommen. Ihr kannst so alles machen, genau, aber ah, ich will Fußball spielen, okay, die nimmt sie fest, bringt sie aufs Revier, ja, ihr habt gewonnen, die sind übrigens wahnsinnig gefährlich und tschüss. Ciao, ciao. Einfach so schnell jetzt geht aus der Geschichte ciao! Alle sind weggerannt, weil es war eine Popcornmaschine, da völlig egal, ciao! Und deswegen bei uns, glaube ich, war es gang und gäbe, dass bei uns alle Aufsätze, bestimmt 80 Prozent der Aufsätze enden mit und er wachte auf und es war alles nur ein Traum, weil das einfach die schnellstmögliche Art ist, um aus der Story rauszukommen, einfach irgendwie Playstation spielen zu können. Das ist hier, das muss man sozusagen alles Klassenarbeiten, also die haben irgendwann einfach aufgehört, weil einfach die Zeit vorbei war und man muss dann als Zehnjähriger ein Ende finden. Aber wie lange haben die denn gedauert so? Weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie lange man für eineinhalb Stunden braucht als Kleinkind. Eineinhalb Stunden? Äh, wie lange man für eineinhalb Seiten braucht als Kleinkind, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Fragen wir euch Zehnjährige da draußen, wie lange braucht ihr für eineinhalb Seiten?
Ich finde, das ist, ähm, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie ich das gemeint habe, es ist auf mehreren Ebenen zu verstehen, ähm, es ist wahnsinnig verstörend, das ist wirklich eine Geschichte, wo ich dachte, was ist eigentlich mit mir falsch, ähm, ich glaube, es ist der erste Sketch, den ich geschrieben habe. Okay, geil! Ich glaube, es war nicht zweideutig gemeint, es ist einfach nur, ich muss mich davor entschuldigen, ich muss mich jetzt schon rechtfertigen. Eine kleine Abkühlung.
Es ist Sommer, der Himmel ist wolkenlos und ab und zu weht ein erfrischendes Lüftchen. Ein kleiner schwarzeriger Junge läuft fröhlich zu seinem Vater, der gerade seinen kleinen Trabant abspritzt. Der Junge fragt, kannst du einen Moment deine Klapperkiste in Ruhe lassen und mich besprühen? Sein Vater antwortet, na klar bespritze ich dich. Nein! Man muss als Lehrerin das korrigieren und denkt auch sich, Jesus, um dem soll ich jetzt eine gute Note geben? Na klar, okay, nochmal. Sein Vater antwortete, na klar bespritze ich dich. Er drehte sich um und besprüht ihn. Der Junge wird nass und freut sich. Er tanzt auf der Stelle und plötzlich stösste einen Freudenschrei aus. Oh nein! Er tanzt auf der Stelle und plötzlich stösste einen Freudenschrei aus. Das hört seine Schwester. Nein! Stefan! Was machst du? Nicht noch mehr Kinder? Oh Gott! Ne, lass den Polizisten aufdrehen, aber bitte keine Kinder! Polizisten! Oh nein, oh nein! Ich kann meine Kinder geraten, vorbeigelaufen. Ja, Freunde! Okay, weiter geht's. Das hört seine Schwester. Sie kommt erwartungsvoll angelaufen. Sie ist ein kleines, blondes, zähliches Mädchen. Sie fragt auch ihren Vater. Kannst du mich besprühen? Bei meinem Bruder hast du es auch gemacht. Wartest du mir? Auf einmal kommt eine sehr grosse und sehr alte Fußgängerin anmarschiert. Endlich! Okay, Lichtblick, Lichtlicht! Oh Gott, klack ihn an! Der Vater dreht sich nicht um, sondern hält nur den Schlauch nach hinten und das Wasser schiesst aus dem Schlauch. Das allerdings erreichte nicht das Mädchen, sondern die alte Fussgängerin, die aufschreit und wie vom Donner gerührt, schaute sie den Mann sprachlos an. Sie ging empört weg und alle lachten. Aber ein Gag am Ende. Slapstick-Gag, der hat nicht im Text funktionieren. Ja, das stimmt. Visueller Humor. Visueller Humor. Oh, da muss ich aber muss ich aber echt lachen. Das ist zum ersten Mal gelesen. Das ist ja fantastisch. Grossartig. Von was denkt man als Lehrerin? Von dieser fordernde Junge. Hör mal auf, deine alte Klapperkisse zu bespritzen und spritz mich an. Jesus. Oh Gott. Wow. Aber das ist doch, ich glaube, Grundschullehrer ist doch mit der beste Fucking-Beruf Weißt du, Grundschullehrer könnten einen ganzen Podcast machen und nur den ganzen Scheiss vorlesen, den ihre Kinder publizieren. Das finde ich nicht schlecht, also wir sollten auf jeden Fall mal einen Grundschullehrer einladen. Auf jeden Fall. Das finde ich super. Das Beste war, und ich fand es auch geil, dass unser Lateinlehrer da Humor hatte, der halt am Ende des Jahres, wenn kein Unterricht mehr wirklich war, hatte immer so das Best-of des Jahres vorgelesen, von was für einem Schwachsinn Leute übersetzt haben. Bei Latein gab es halt viele Deppen in der letzten Reihe, die keine Ahnung haben, dass irgendwas geschrieben hat. Bei uns mal der Gag ganz kurz Debello Gallico, also vom Gallischen Krieg. Der Hund. Der gallische Hund, ja. Der gallische Hund, ja. Irgendwie so, wow. Man braucht Abitur für diesen Gag. Das habe ich viel lustiger in Erinnerung. Das ist ist einfach mir der uncool Akademiker-Gag. Bei uns war ein legendärer Satz, weil du hast ja, irgendwann hast du ja ein Lexikon bei Latein und schlägst einfach jedes einzelne Wort nach und hast eine Reihe an Worten, hast aber keine Ahnung, wie du die grammatikalisch irgendwie anordnen kannst. Versuchst irgendwie in einen Satz zu packen, was aber unmöglich erscheint. Und bei uns tatsächlich auch... Dunkelheitsschatz, wie soll ich das in einen Satz bekommen? Ja, und dann hat man einfach den Satz mehr oder weniger an jemanden gestellt und hat geguckt, wie kann man die Worte irgendwie verbinden. Ein legendärer Satz bei uns. Herkules stand heftig schäumend auf dem Dach und ein Tiger ging neben dem Brunnen. Das ist so... Vor allem das sind so zwei komplett unterschiedliche Szenarien. Aber beides geiles hier nachher. Hercules stand heftig schäumend auf dem Dach und by the way, ein Tiger läuft neben dem Boden. Sorry Leute, was ist hier eigentlich los? Kurz um die Szenen einzuordnen. Als wäre das so, die Kamera zoomt weg, aber der Zuschauer will eigentlich noch wissen, was mit Hercules war. So wow wow wow wow, wow, wow, wow, langsam, langsam. Oh, ein Tiger! Wo, wo, wo, wo! Okay, Simon den Tiger! Nein, nicht zurück! Nicht durchschäumen!
Genauso waren ganze Lateinaufsätze immer so, wenn es interessant wurde.
Aber vielleicht auch, vielleicht hat es aber auch Sinn ergeben, vielleicht war es einfach nur wahnsinnig, so ein Erzähler, so ein Kind spricht plötzlich, das war wirklich die richtige Übersetzung, hätte es auch sein können.
Es war übrigens auch De Bello Finito, also Der Krieg ist vorbei, handelt übersetzt mit Der Hund ist tot. De Bello Finito. Nicht schlecht. Aber sehr lustig. Lustig, lustig. Vor allem vom Grundschullehrer haben wir ja auch so viel in der Hand. Also die Kinder vertrauen ja alles an. Ja, ja. Und die können denen einfach, was zum Beispiel sehr lustig, wenn man das Wort für Stuhl nicht beibringt oder so. Einfach, wenn man Kinder einfach komplett manipulieren. Deswegen, wenn ich nicht mal Kinder habe, werde ich das auf jeden Fall auch irgendwie. Komplett falsche Worte erklären. Wie gesagt, die ersten fünf Jahre. Einfach danke, danke, einfach danke, fick dich beibringen. Ja, genau. Und einfach komplett erfundene Worte. Komplett gegen die Wand laufen lassen, intellektuell. Ja. Finde ich super lustig. Ja. Als Grundleger hast du einfach auch die Mittel. Ja, vor allem, das wird ja auch so die Notengebung und so, das kontrolliert ja kein Mensch, die können ja sagen, was sie wollen. Ob die Geschichte jetzt gut oder nicht, so scheiß, das ist random, why, ist das völlig egal. Die würfeln einfach Noten aus, so ja, keine Ahnung, was soll ich denn wissen. Aber ich muss echt mal nachgucken, ob ich sowas vielleicht auch finde. Weil ich kann mich an einige Storys erinnern, die ich geschrieben habe und es war schon echt ziemlich grosser Crap, aber es war interessant interessant, tatsächlich, weil ich habe immer versucht, möglichst kreative Geschichten zu schreiben, weil mein Bruder... Ja, sorry, das war auch mein Ansatz, kam es vielleicht nicht so durch, aber... Nein, weil mein Bruder hat mir nur einen einzigen Tipp gegeben, mein Bruder hat mir ständig Tipps gegeben für solche Sachen, und er hat gesagt, überleg dir, weil da war dann immer so die Aufgabe zum Beispiel Zeitmaschine, überleg dir, was alle schreiben und schreib was anderes. War das der gleiche Bruder, der gesagt hat, am Ende des Referats muss die wichtigste Information kommen? Ja, genau der, genau der. Cool, guter Bruder. Ja. Lebt der noch? Nee. Ist gestern. An Darmkrebs gestorben. An Horn-Schilddrüsenkrebs. Hornkrebs. Leider gestorben. Geil. Aber man kann so einfach das Leben zerstören. vor allem muss ich erzählen, ein paar interner jetzt tatsächlich. Wir hatten ja mal im Neo Magazin so eine Rubrik Selfie of your life geschnitten wegen interner.
Ich hab noch mehr Geschichten und wir könnten das noch ein paar mal machen, aber ich find's auch geil, wenn ihr da draussen, liebe Leute, mal irgendwie Geschichten einscannen von euch damals. Ey, das wär supergut.
Wenn ihr das habt, wir machen so eine Rubrik und dann können wir mit verteilten Rollen irgendwie immer so eine Rubrik abfeuern, wo wir Kindergeschichten ausmachen. Oder alles, was ihr findet aus eurer Schulzeit, alte Bilder oder so, irgendwie so Sachen, die jetzt einfach rückblickend total weird sind. Wir werden sie auf jeden Fall verarbeiten und ich gucke auch mal, ob ich noch irgendwas finde. Guck, ob du was findest, ist super lustig. Ich habe auch noch ein paar alte Sachen von mir gefunden, aber da war ich schon älter, da war ich schon so 15, 16 und so. Ich glaube, das ist nicht lustig genug, weil es einfach schon zu... Total, Florentorentin Will vor der Aufnahme, die sind einfach zu gut. Die sind halt zu, die sind schon schlecht, aber es ist nicht so schlecht, dass sie lustig sind. Florentin Will ist neben, wenn die Kamera aus ist, das Mikrofon aus, einfach ein wahnsinniges Arschloch. Sorry, aber die Geschichten sind einfach zu gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den Podcast noch weitermachen kann, ich glaube, ich bin einfach zu gut dafür. Ich bin zu gut für dich, sorry, ciao. Gebt mir nichts mehr irgendwie, ichiss es nicht. Ne, ist ja lustig, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall mal machen.
Wenn ihr eher draußen Geschichten habt, einfach mal einscannen oder so. Nicht irgendwie Dinge ausdenken, ich habe Angst, dass ihr das ausdenken sehe ich jetzt. Ja, oder denkt euch was aus, haut mal was raus. Ich habe letztens gefordert, in der letzten Folge, dass ihr mal was raushaut und ich habe überhaupt nichts rausgehauen. Ich habe diesen Satz rausgeschnitten, glaube ich, dass du das sagst. Ja, okay, dann wiederhole ich jetzt, also noch mal ganz kurz. Es ist so gut, dass du dich immer wunderst, dass es nicht mehr darauf eingeht und im Nachhinein kommt raus, dass es nicht zu stellen, nie drin, dass ich dich komplett rausgeschnitten habe. Warum gibt niemand auf mich im Podcast ein, nicht weil ich ihn komplett rausschneide. Das ist nur ich, ein Riesenmonolog. Warum sagen die immer nur, ich finde Stefan total gut, warum erwähnen die nie mich einfach? Warum steht in der Podcast-Beschreibung auch mein Name gar nicht? Und die erwähnen immer Gustav und Christian, was sind das für Leute, was machst du, schneidest du da ständig rein, was soll das?
Nein, aber wir vom Podcast UFO, wir sind vielleicht nicht der beste Podcast, der netteste, der unterhaltsamste, der klügste, der lustigste. Wo wir gerade diese hilarious Geschichte aus dem Nähemagazin intern erzählt haben, die wir rausgestimmt haben, was ich auch lustig finde zu sagen, Mir ist natürlich aufgefallen, es ein Ziel von mir ist, dass ich, wenn ich sterbe, zumindest eine Folge, wenn ich jetzt sterben würde, würde ich mir wünschen, dass eine Folge Neomagazin aussetzt. Also, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich noch nicht in der Lage bin, an dem ich sterbe jetzt, glaube ich, wird es trotzdem eine Sendung nächste Woche geben. Davon gehe ich stark aus. Das hat mich dann fertig gemacht. Also, kurz in so einem lustigen Moment. Ich würde sagen, nicht mal das Podcast-Ufo setzt aus, wie du stirbst und ganz erkenlos sein. Ralf Rute, Max Bierhals, überhaupt keinen Stress, ich mach weiter. Und die Hörerzeiten würden wahrscheinlich, ich sag mal, steigen. Ich bin jetzt so lustig, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, wenn man jetzt sterben würde, was alles passieren würde, und ich gehe davon aus, dass die Sendung nächste Woche... So gut wie gar nichts passiert. Es würde nichts passieren. Meine Eltern würden traurig sein, Fräule würden traurig sein, du willst nächste Woche einen neuen Podcast haben, machen besseren Podcast mal. Ich bin dein Klotz am Bein los. Stefan Schwier und ich, weißt du, da muss man nicht mal die ganzen Titel ändern, weil Stefan einfach stimmt. Wir machen einfach eins zu eins direkt so weiter. Ja, genau, man macht auch einen Namensgag, so der Nachname auch völlig egal, das ist einfach austauschbar. Leute, komm, hier werden alle durchgewunken. Finde ich so lustig, das ist einfach, es wird alles vorbei gemacht, also das ist total lustig, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, was passieren würde. Stefan Schwirr, Schwirr, so einfach die Gagelzeile. Wenn du sterben würdest, glaubst du, es wird auch eine Sendung geben nächste Woche noch? Ja, natürlich. Ich glaube auch. Was müssen wir denn erreichen, damit eine Sendung ausfällt für uns? Na, es kommt auch ein bisschen darauf an, wie man stirbt, glaube ich. Also ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie... Wenn man stirbt, gibt es auch eine Sendung, glaubst du? Ja, doch, glaube ich schon. Ich glaube, es gibt immer eine Sendung. Meinst du, welcher Tod meinst du? Also wenn Jan stirbt auf jeden Fall. Ja klar. Es wäre interessant zu sehen, was dann passiert. Bin ich, angenommen, ich sterbe bei einem Fallschirmsprung. Nee, dann nicht. Ich glaube, wenn du jetzt in einem Anschlag, im Terroristenanschlag stirbst, dann könnte man vielleicht sagen, okay, heikel, heikel, heikel, heikel. Aber wenn du einfach so ganz stinknormal am Herzinfarkt stirbst oder irgendwo runterfällst, wo ich davon ausgehe, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass du sterben bist, wenn du von irgendwo runterfällst, weil du bist sehr gross, selbst wenn du nur über den Bordstein stürzt, ist das immer schon lebensbewertig. Ich fall sehr tief, 300 Meter tief. Das ist nur ein Nachteil eigentlich, wenn du so gross bist. Ach, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. Nee Stimmt doch nicht. Du kannst dich mit Leuten unterhalten, die wir überhaupt nicht sehen, wir unten, die wir da zwischen anderen Menschen stehen.
Mit grossen Menschenmenge hast du nur Vorteile. Du wirst gesehen und du kannst sehen.
Als Krieger zum Beispiel, also wenn ich mal eine Zeitreise machen würde.
Würden alle sofort dich angreifen, wenn man dich als erstes sieht.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich wäre einfach so eine Art Troll und würde einfach alle sofort killen können.
Aber ich glaube, ab der Erfindung der Schusswaffe hast du wieder grosse Probleme.
Ich glaube, da war es sehr gut, sehr klein zu sein.
Habe ich sehr grosse Probleme, sehr gut. Ja. Vielleicht kriegst du auch eine grössere Waffe deswegen. Oder kannst du wie ein Geist aussehen oder so, sowas in der Art. Was, wenn du einen Gegenstand mitnehmen müsstest, zu einer Zeitreise in die Vergangenheit, zum Beispiel das Mittelalter, was würdest du mitnehmen? Sehr gute Frage. Handy bringt dir nichts, null. Kannst du es nicht aufladen, du kannst damit niemanden erreichen. Ist ja die Frage, entweder du überlegst, was dir am meisten nützt, oder womit kannst du am ehesten deine Dominanz und deine Überlegenheit beweisen. Du kannst ja sagen, was heißt ich, zum Beispiel ein Feuerzeug, dann kann ich gut Feuer machen, was Leute im Mittelalter auch können, was überhaupt nichts bringt. Aber nee, ich würde wahrscheinlich irgendwas nehmen, was so ganz anders ist als alles, was die Leute erkennen. Dein Schwert. Umzumachen, mein schlecht geschmiedetes Schwert. Ist das ein echtes Schwert eigentlich? Könntest du damit Leute umbringen? Ja, ja, es ist ein echte Schwert. Es ist halt nicht scharf, aber man könnte... Aber es könnte scharf gemacht werden. Ja. Dann wäre es doch sogar ein gutes Schwert vielleicht sogar. Es ist nicht so gut ausbalanciert, aber das sind Details, die muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt. Oh Gott. Ist das irgendwie so ein Gag, so ein Schaumstoff-Styropor-Schwert oder so? Nee, ich glaube, ich würde wahrscheinlich mitnehmen ein Auto. Ja gut, aber lass doch keinen Benzin mehr irgendwann. Ja gut, aber du kannst ja trotzdem noch eine Weile fahren. Ohne Benzin? Und dann fährst du durch die Hygiene und sagst, what the fuck, was ist das denn? Aber es gibt ja keine Strassen, ne? Ein Auto ist extrem dumm, weil es gibt keine Strassen. Jeep. Ja, aber Jeeps sind mega uncool, mit Jeeps kommst du einfach nicht an bei Leuten. Ja, guck dir den Depp mal an. Ne, das funktioniert nicht. Ciao. Macht's gut, tschöne Woche noch, bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein, neo, neo, frei oder radikal, wir sind ja neo. Ich würde wahrscheinlich meinen Pokal mitnehmen, dass ich mal vierter Platz geworden bin im Karate-Turnier. Und dann kann ich allen sagen, hey Leute, guckt euch mal diesen Pokal. Ich kann mal eine Frage, was ist Karate? Karate sagen, also man darf ab dem blauen Gürtel davon Karate sagen, davor heißt es Karate. Karate. Ja genau. Und Krate ist eine fernöstliche Kampfsportart, die sehr tödlich ist. Cool. Die macht meinen Körper zur Waffe und meine Waffe zu meinem Körper. Und darum geht's hauptsächlich. Wahrscheinlich einfach Gold mitnehmen, oder? Ja. Ich meine, ich habe ja kein Gold, aber wahrscheinlich ist Gold, Gold ist ja immer genauso viel wert, deswegen. Ich finde es interessant, dass nichts, was wir hier besitzen von Wert wäre im Mittelalter, dass einfach die Sachen, die wert sind, immer von der Zeit abhängen, wo man sie gerade hat. Also man schlägt immer so ein bisschen seine Wertblasung mit sich herum, aber die ändert sich auch ständig. Und so irgendwann war mal das iPhone mega viel wert. Wahrscheinlich das Beste wäre so etwas wie eine Formelsammlung oder so etwas, wo halt wahnsinnig viel Wissen drin ist. Tatsächlich. Und halt solche Sachen, wo du einfach an die Uni gissst und sagst, Leute, ich habe halt einfach alles gecheckt. Einfach ein Buch und deine Lesekenntnisse. Irgendwann dein Gedächtnis isteste, was du alles weißt. Man denkt ja immer, man würde jetzt in die Vergangenheit reisen und würde dann alles revolutionieren. Aber auf der anderen Seite gehe ich dann zu Karl Friedrich, dem Kaiser und sage, ey, in der Zukunft gibt es so kleine, kleine schwarze Kästen, mit denen kann man telefonieren. Echt, wie funktionieren die denn? Also, das sind so... Ja, habt die doch, habt die doch, du musst doch wissen, wie funktionieren die Dinge, die du... Ja, aber, ja, wir haben auch so ganz grosse Metallpferde, mit denen kann man durch die Gegend fahren ganz schnell. Ach, das ist ja super. Und wir bauen uns doch mal eins. Ja, also, ist halt schwer mit... Und wir sind auch zum Mond geflogen. Dieses Ding, was da oben die ganze Zeit kommt nachts? Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Los! Ja gut, habt ihr Nitro? Wir haben noch ein bisschen Nitro im Keller, ja. Habt ihr Nitro? Ja, wir haben noch ein Kessel Nitro, aber dann ist ja kein Problem. Aber ich könnte euch die erste Staffel Sopranos nacherzählen, wenn ihr wollt. Ich glaube, ich würde mich als Zauberer ausgeben und die ganze Zeit Dachen spoilern. Ja, Game of Thrones. Genau, du weißt ja, was schon passiert. John Snow, du wirst so sterben. Sorry. Oder auch nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe die Bücher nicht gelesen. Vielleicht stirbst du. Aber hütet euch vor Jar Jar Binks, wenn ihr den seht, dann ist es schwierig. Aber sowas in der Richtung. Ich würde sagen, Alexander der Grosse, du wirst umgebracht werden. Glaub ich, da habe ich mir da aufgepasst. Entweder du oder der Typ, der in 800 Jahren regiert. So Verwirrung stiften. Also, warte, warte, warte, warte, wir sind hier in Frankreich. War die französische Revolution schon? Ihr werdet den nächsten Krieg verlieren, dann wieder verlieren, dann zwei gewinnen, dann verlieren und dann geht euer Reich unter. Genau, so war es alles. Und dann kommen die Deutschen. Genau. Divorced, beheaded, died, divorced, beheaded, survived. Leute, so könnt ihr euch die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, died. Divorced, beheaded, survived. Wir machen doch mal Merksätze jetzt gerade. Merksätze. Okay, also ich habe zwei Merksätze für euch. So merkt ihr euch, was mit den sechs Ehefrauen von Henry V passiert ist. Divorced, beheaded, died. Divorced, beheaded, survived. Okay, von mir lernt ihr unsere Planeten. Mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unsere neun Planeten. Merkur, Venus, gut, Merkur, Venus, Erde, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptun, in Klammern Pluto. Und worüber redet ihr denn so in eurem Podcast mit 10.000 Hörern? Wir zählen die Planeten auf hauptsächlich, also was in der Richtung. Aber was könnte ein neuer Satz sein? Unsere neuen Planeten? Mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unsere Nachthimmel. Unser Nachthimmel. Ey, das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist mega gut. Erklärt uns unseren Nachthimmel. Erklärt mir unseren Nachthimmel. Einen ganz kleinen Teil. Erklärt mir einen Bruchteil unseres Nachthimmels. Ich glaube, das war das Klügste, was du jemals gesagt hast. Von mir kriegt jetzt noch, wie kann man sich die vier Aufgaben des Skeletts merken? Ganz einfach, Spam, Support, protection, anchorage, movement. Masturbation. Spam, masturbation, support, protection, anchorage, movement. Ich kann mir die Merkklässe immer gut merken, aber nie, was es bedeutet. Wovor kann das M stehen? Marso, me, marschieren. Wir haben heute tatsächlich, Stefan und ich haben uns ein bisschen schlauer gemacht über das Thema Sex. Das ist ein Thema, das sich in unserer Zukunft vielleicht so ergeben wird. Und wir wollen vorbereitet sein, Stefan und ich. Und wir haben einige interessante Dinge gelernt. Wir haben nämlich einen Artikel gelesen, die Fehler, die Männer am häufigsten bei Sex machen. Bei Sex. Wenn sie Sex machen, dann machen sie diese Fehler. Und ich sag mal, da kam uns vieles bekannt vor. Vor allem sollte der Artikel eigentlich lauten, wenn Sie diesen Artikel lesen, machen Sie alle Fehler, die Sie machen können. Wahrscheinlich schon. Ja, wir haben Bingo gespielt. Ich glaube, ich hatte mehr abgehakt als du am Ende. Und ein Punkt war tatsächlich, und da muss ich auch mal sagen, das wirft mich, sag ich mal, sexuell auch nochmal vier Jahre zurück, hieß es, wie viele Männer denken, die Vagina würde sich am selben Ort befinden wie der Penis.
Und da muss ich dann doch schon mal ganz kurz nochmal nachdenken.
Moment, wie war das Shit?
Moment mal, hallo Frau Titzel, schön Sie zu sehen, na na na na na und dann, aber eigentlich ist doch schon, also oder? Shit, ich muss ganz gut jemanden anrufen, ich muss kurz telefonieren. Was habe ich mit den Leuten gemacht? Laura, es tut mir leid, ich weiß nicht, was an dem Abend passiert. Ich weiß noch damals, ich weiß nicht, was in mich gefahren ist, aber ich dachte, das wäre da, wo auch bei mir... Ja, also ich dachte, das würde sich mehr oder weniger spiegeln, so sorry. Also nein, aber ganz kurz... Nein, das verunsichert einen noch mehr, als es einem hilft. Aber mal ganz kurz, um mal ganz kurz Sex zu erklären. Man liegt auf dem Rücken, die Frau liegt neben einem auf dem Rücken, wartet dann, bis der Pizzabote reinkommt. Deswegen ist es in Pornos auch mal Pizzabote. Der übernimmt dann. Und der übernimmt dann das Problem. Genau. Und man selber geht an wieder. Und das Kind sieht dann aus wie der Pizzabote. Das ist die Regel. Das ist aber wunderlich, aber das Kind sieht dann immer aus wie der Pizzabote, der da reinkam. Also wenn der Pizzabote reinkommt, sieht er schon, ach, oh no, es ist der dicke, der dicke Rothaarige. Meine Freundin meinte letztens zu mir, wir sollten mal Doggy-Style ausprobieren. Also habe ich sie im Wald ausgesetzt. Nochmal liebe Grüße an meine Mutter an der Stelle. Ist er von dir? Ne, ne. Das war ein Tweet, den ich geschrieben habe, aber er ist nicht gut angekommen. Sag doch mal eine Feedline. Meine Freundin meinte letztens zu mir, wir sollten mal Doggy-Style ausprobieren. Also habe ich gesagt, okay.
Also habe ich Erdnussbutter auf mein Glied geschmiert.
Finde ich die bessere?
Ja, finde ich gut.
Warte, ich mache noch einen.
Meine Freundin meinte letztens, wir sollten mal Doggy-Style ausprobieren.
Also bin ich einem Auto hinterhergelaufen.
Okay.
Meine Freundin meinte letztens, wir sollten mal Doggy-Style ausprobieren. Also habe ich angefangen, mich mit meinem Spiegelbild zu prügeln, mich mit ihrem Spiegelbild zu prügeln. Unser Spiegel ist daraufhin zu Bruch gegangen, wo kann ich neue Spiegel kaufen? Das finde ich auch geil, wenn es abdriften einfach. Ja, abdriften. Ganz nebenbei Frage, wo kann man neue Spiele kaufen. Ja, ich habe mit dem Schwanz gewählt, das ist natürlich ein bisschen einfach. Ich habe mich mit der Katze gestritten. Ja, sowas, ne? Also denkt euch auch mal selber ein paar Pointen aus. Wir sind ja wie gesagt mehr so die Feedline-Leute. Ganz kurz, geschnitten wegen Stefan. Ist einfach so erschreckend, wenn man auf sein Handy guckt und acht verpasste Anrufe von derselben Nummer hat. Oh. Dann denkt man sich auch so, what? Vor allem im Podcast-Projekt, wo man merkt, dass man halt die nächsten, obwohl es sehr wichtig ist, die nächsten acht Minuten nicht mehr rangehen kann. Ja, vor allem es sind acht Anrufe von einer unbekannten Nummer. Und wo man sich denkt, welches Anliegen könnte eine unbekannte Nummer mit mir haben, dass es so dringend ist, dass sie achtmal anruft. Soll ich mal anrufen jetzt? Ruf mal jetzt live an. Wenn es jetzt die Massagesessel-Hotline ist, die beschwert, dass wir sie in den Podcast geschnitten haben, haben wir die rausgeschnitten eigentlich damals oder haben wir die gehört? Nein, die hat man gehört. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Doch, klar. Aber da hat letztens jemand darauf Bezug genommen, dass man das schon hört. Bitte, bitte sei nichts Unangenehmes. Hanna hier.
Äh, hallo, guten Tag.
Hi. Hallo, Johanna hier. Hallo, Johanna. Hallo, ich wollte noch mal mit dir sprechen, weil's ja morgen schon so früh losgeht, ob das auch okay für dich ist überhaupt. Das ist alles in Ordnung, ich bin morgen ja eh da, also ab neun, dann im Studio C. Nein, es geht ja wirklich los.
Caro hat mir gerade erzählt, dass sie eben eineinhalb Stunden braucht für deine Maske und fürs Kostüm und so weiter, weil sie dir ganz kleine Locken drehen wollen.
Und deswegen müsstest du schon um Viertel nach sieben im Studio C sein.
Aha, okay, alles klar.
Ganz schön früh, ne?
Ja, ne, ist okay. Ich freue mich.
Ja, cool, okay, super. Dann müssen wir morgen. Die Dispo kommt auch gleich noch. Alles klar, du bist auch gerade live im Podcast-Ufo übrigens, in unserem Podcast mit Stefan und mir. Ach so, okay, hallo. Willst du noch einen... Hallo, Johanna. Willst du noch einen Gruß an unsere Hörer raushauen? Natürlich, selbstverständlich. Ich grüsse alle Hörer vom Podcast-Ufo. Wunderbar, vielen Dank, alles klar. Die Hörer überhaupt. Super, bis morgen. Gut, da müssen wir morgen, mach's gut, ne. Oh Mann, ey, viertel nach sieben, ey. Was ist denn das für eine Scheisse, ey? Weil was eigentlich hier sein muss, um halb acht, vier Stunden länger, nein, ich muss um halb acht. Vor allem, auch gut, ja, um viertel nach sieben, damit wir dir kleine Löckchen drehen können, also okay, klar, da lohnt es sich natürlich auch zu stehen. Fickt euch. Naja, muss man tun, ne, manchmal ist man ja auch... Ach,, jetzt hör mal aus, du hast einen schwierigen Job hier. Nee, ich mach das total gerne. Ist ja in Ordnung. Ist ja wunderbar in Ordnung. Na ja, wie wirst du eigentlich, angenommen, du bist morgen eher sehr lange, bist du frisiert. Ja. Da musst du ja auch Smalltalk halten und es ist ja oft für uns ... Was machst du dann? Also worüber sprichst du dann? Über Serien, über das Wetter, über Serien, über das Wetter oder über das Wetter? Ne, ich erzähle dann einfach irgendeinen Schwachsinn, tatsächlich. Also es ist tatsächlich auch gut, wenn man irgendwann merkt, man hat die Fähigkeit, einfach gut fünf Stunden am Stück zu labern, ohne Probleme. Es ist tatsächlich gut, das zu merken, dass wenn du dich mit jemandem triffst oder irgendeine Situation mit einer anderen Person alleine hast, auch einfach mal labern kannst ohne weiteres und das kann ich mittlerweile, ich kann einfach labern. Es kommt im Podcast oft nicht so rüber, aber das ist ja auch eine andere Qualitätsstufe, vor allem zumal hier kann ich ja nicht alles das erzählen, was ich im Podcast schon erzählt habe und wir müssen überlegen, wir haben jetzt schon 40 Folgen gemacht, das heißt, jeder von uns hat schon 20 Stunden gesprochen. Du kannst nicht alles erzählen, was öffentlich ist, und zweitens, du hast schon viele Sachen erzählt, das sind zwei Dinge, die jetzt nicht bis wirr gemacht haben. Ja, und es wird ja auch immer die fucking Hälfte rausgeschnitten. Das heißt, ich habe ja an sich schon doppelt so viele Sachen erzählt, wie Stefan Tesco hier irgendwie ständig rausschneidet von mir, gerade meine ganzen privaten Intimsachen, wie ich hier immer mein Herz öffne und den Zuschauern eigentlich vor die Füsse werfen möchte, schneidet Stefan Knallhardt raus. Und deswegen kann man das alles erzählen. Ja, weil du andauernd deine Handynummer verrätst und sagst, dass die heißen Girls unserer Hörer dich anrufen sollen. Nur weil ich hier bettelnd am Boden liege und sage, dass mich irgendjemand anrufen soll, dass ich mega einsam bin, heisst das doch nicht, dass es irgendwie erbärmlich ist oder so. Voll erbärmlich, dann mache ich alles raus. Das kann man ja mal machen. Nein, aber das ist ja tatsächlich so. Wenn eine Person meinen Twitter-Feed nicht kennt und meine Podcast nicht kennt, meine drei Bücher nicht gelesen hat und meinen Spielfilm nicht gesehen hat, dann habe ich acht Stunden Material, die man denen einfach mal um die Ohren hauen kann. Ja, das stimmt. Und einfach mal sagen kann, hier, da mal. Aber hast du dafür Dinge auswendig gelernt? Also hast du dafür klare Strukturen in deinem Kopf, wo du das auswendig, oder rufst du einfach ab, wo das Thema gerade hinführt, hast du ein Repertoire auch. Ja, ich komme dann einfach von einem Punkt zum anderen und rede dann einfach. Klassisches Repertoire, was du dir auch gebaut hast. hast, ne? Es kommt so ein bisschen auf die Anspruchsfülle der Person an, mit der ich rede. Uns fehlen oft Wörter, das ist einfach das Problem. Ja, wir haben einfach zu wenig Worte. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt auch schon langsam alle einfach verwendet. Schwerer mit mir zu sprechen als mit jemandem anderen, weil wir halt schon auch unser Repertoire einfach kennen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und vor allem ist ja auch das Niveau viel höher. Man kann ja nicht einfach alles... Es ist ja tatsächlich so ein... Es Es gibt ja so zwei Arten, wenn man sich... Das Niveau ist höher, mit mir zu sprechen. Ja klar, natürlich, weil du anspruchsvoller bist und ich nicht ihnen Scheiss einfach erzählen kann. Aber warum bin ich denn anspruchsvoller? Naja, weil du mich gut kennst, weil du weißt, wozu ich fähig bin, weil du Ahnung von Comedy hast und weil du generell einen hohen Anspruch hast. Ich unter 80% deliveren, weil ich weiss, dass du merken würdest, dass ich unter 80% deliver, weil du weisst, was mein Spektrum ist. Wenn ich eine Person völlig neu kennenlerne, kann ich auf 50% arbeiten und die Person mag völlig zufrieden sein und sagen, ja, ist ein netter Typ, aber ich habe noch wesentlich mehr Potenzial und kann einfach mehr raushauen. Je mehr eindrücken will, desto schwerer ist es natürlich, mit dieser Person zu reden, weil du hast höhere Ansprüche und du kannst nicht alles raushauen. Was der Grund ist, warum wir Jan Böhmer nicht einladen. Absolut, aber absolut. Ja klar, ja und vor allem, man ist ja noch eingeschüchtert und das hält dann ja auch zurück. Auf jeden Fall. Wenn du gut sein möchtest, bist du ja auch nicht. Ja genau, das ist ja dieser Zugzwang, dieser Performancezwang, der nicht gut ist. Ja. Nee, nicht gut ist. Aber auch wichtig ist, weil man darf den Anspruch nicht verloren. Wenn du keinen Performance-Zwang hast, dann ist es egal, was du sagst. Und dann wirst du schlampig. Alles klar. Cool. Ja. Ciao. Gut, ciao. Feierabend machen. Mach's gut. Ja, vielen Dank. Mach's gut. Ja, vielen Dank, falls ihr euch fragt, warum die Folge nur 30 Minuten lang ist. Nein. Wie haben wir jetzt aufgenommen? Ich sehe die Uhr zum ersten Mal. Eine Stunde zwanzig. Aber falls ihr euch fragt, warum sie nur 30 Minuten lang ist, Stefan hat mal wieder die grosse Schnittschere angesetzt. Der grosse Scherenmann aus dem Strubelpeter. Stefan hat tatsächlich seine grosse Berufung gefunden und ist der grosse böse Scherenmann. Ja, ihr könnt nicht entscheiden, wollt ihr der Down-Litcher sein oder der coole Scherenmann. Ich habe jetzt die Wahl.
Wir machen eine Twitter-Obenfrage.